this morning the beginning of a new
trilogy by one of the most acclaimed
authors in america
don winslow is the veteran crime writer
behind dozens of books including savages
and the death and life of bobby z both
of which were turned into movies
starting 17 years ago he began releasing
a trilogy about the war on drugs
bestsellers the power of the dog the
cartel and the border
now he's turned his focus to the irish
and italian mobs of new england a
subject he's wanted to write about for
decades
city on fire is the first of three
planned books a beginning for him
and as we learned also
an end
danny ryan watches the woman come out of
the water like a vision emerging from
his dreams of the sea
except she's real and she's going to be
trouble
women that beautiful usually are
the book starts right here east matunic
state beach this is actually called
jerusalem don winslow's epic new trilogy
starts in the place he knows better than
anywhere else
the place that raised him
coastal rhode island how much of the
book is rooted in real history oh most
of it
it's nothing but a lot of hook wick real
life mob stories were splashed across
headlines here for decades
stories winslow blended with his own
past including years working as a
private investigator
before he became one of the most famous
crime writers in america i had this idea
quite a while ago about
there was an incident that took place on
a beach
between italian and irish lobsters
and
it sounded to me like helen of troy the
hero of city on fire part of a
three-book series that winslow's already
finished is danny ryan a longshoreman
constantly pulled between established
criminal codes of violence and
retribution
and his better instincts
under winslow's watch ryan becomes just
as memorable as his last great hero
dea agent art keller
the main character in a previous winslow
trilogy that focused on the war on drugs
i spent more time with art keller than
i've spent with any other real human
being in my life
i was 23 years with that character
virtually every day
uh danny not much less than that i i
think the the catholicism that i grew up
in is present in both of them big time
big time maybe the the black and white
way of looking at the world
you know in terms of you're very
definitive when you see something that
you believe is wrong yeah or right yeah
yeah
we spoke with winslow inside a playhouse
his parents once operated first opened
in 1933.
this place is theater by the sea in
matunic rhode island
i started here as an actor when i was
12.
this place has a lot of history for the
winslow's
all kinds of people have performed here
uh may west uh wc feels uh groucho marx
marlon brando
henry fonda
my dad was a big burlesque fan he loved
burlesque comics
so i finally wrote a burlesque show you
don't write a burlesque show you type of
the last year
and we did it here with uh jennifer
flowers
was the the jennifer flowers jennifer
flowers was the girl singer in the show
so that's the genesis of don winslow's
storytelling
yeah coming here and
hearing and doing kind of the spoken
word
the if you will the muscularity of words
you know the sounds of them i think was
really key
in recent years winslow has focused his
unique intensity and communication skill
on more than just books
he's become one of the country's most
prominent political activist
peppering his twitter feed with dozens
of posts a day and producing videos
opposing former president donald trump
and republicans
that have been viewed more than 250
million times
for the left it's been heroic work
for the right
it's toxic i get called a lot of names
you know on social media that are
personal and sometimes threatening but
you do a lot of the attacking yourself
on social media now i do
i do but i'm right
it must be nice to feel
that you are right but look you can have
your own opinion but the facts are the
facts
we had a president and we all saw it
jeff
we all heard it we all saw it you saw it
you heard it come on
try to overthrow the government of the
united states
try to overturn
a legal election what are the
consequences this has been almost
singularly the focus of your of your
twitter feed
late last couple months now yeah do you
think people are listening i think so
there are those who would say why are
you focusing on the past and the guy who
was president
instead of the person who is president
and the future
right now because it seems like you talk
a lot more about
trump than you do about biden well
because the past is still with us
and so he's not president anymore they
took away his twitter account they took
away facebook
he's
relegated to sending out
press releases on email right
but there is aiders and there's a
betters
50 of whom 50
people involved in the january 6
insurrection are now candidates for
government office
josh hawley
who was encouraging the rioters
is sitting in the senate spewing his
idiocies
routinely as a piece of
yes
but does that talk just fuel the general
atmosphere of
anger
listen jeff
these people are bullies
they are classic schoolyard bullies
they talk tough and they act tough until
someone punches them in the nose and
then they go running to teacher
i have no problem metaphorically
speaking punching them in the nose it
needs to happen
because winslow believes these times are
so extraordinary he says it's time to
refocus his full attention
so even though he is still at the full
height of his book writing powers
he surprised us
with an announcement
book number three is going to be my last
published book
i am
going to retire you're retiring
yes why
it's time
to do something else
i want to continue on
speaking out
where where i see what i think is wrong
that's a big deal
it is a big deal and it's it's not a
decision that i made easily you know
i think
jeff i've told the stories that i want
to tell
and i don't want to keep
writing just for the sake of publishing
or just for the sake of a paycheck
you know
so i think now is the time
wow don is also constantly supporting
and encouraging other writers on his
twitter feed in other places he says he
wants to continue to do that to bring up
that next generation of writers but hats
off to his writing career i mean it's
it's not easy to write a good book
never mind a trilogy never mind two
trilogies never mind all the other books
that he's done
curious is is does he have political
aspirations
well he certainly wants to continue the
activism that he's taking part in on
social media i would say never easy also
to just follow what your heart tells you
to do as well we'll be right back